FBI is investigating Brett Kavanaugh
this week you all know that right yeah
yeah President Trump is hoping for a
quick probe of Brett Kavanaugh and in
response stormy Daniel said if there's
one thing Trump's good for it's a quick
pro you know everyone's talking about
drinking since the Kavanaugh right you
know in who drinks and who doesn't drink
that's the big question today President
Trump said he doesn't drink and he's
never had a beer in his entire life yeah
yeah Trump said I prefer being the guy
who causes other people to drink that's
my that's my goal in life that's what I
do
this whole section got very angry when I
said Trump had never had a beer after
everything else that's what they're mad
about right First Lady Melania Trump has
embarked on a solo trip to Africa yes
yes when asked when she's coming back
Melania said back
I like those claps thank you thank you
Los Angeles has prosecuted its first
case ever of DUI for someone riding on
an electric bird scooter the specific
charge is douchey under the influence
specifically DUI those those things
aren't meant for drunks they're meant
for stoners I think that's that's a
fundamental I don't see people being
drunk riding those do you I can imagine
it's not good those things go fast I
think it'd be fun to watch in Arizona a
couple's gender-reveal party for their
baby accidentally set off a wild fire
that destroyed 47 thousand acres and
cost eight million dollars in damages on
the bright side it's a girl supported
today that in 1990 in 1990 the US was
6th in the world in education now we're
27th yeah when they when they heard this
Americans asked is that worser Canada
Mexico and us the u.s. I like to call it
Canada Mexico and the US have reached a
new trade agreement to replace NAFTA
yeah under the new deal Mexico will send
us heavy machinery Canada will send us
timber and we'll send one of them Kanye
that's how
[Applause]
you